now I've done so many videos on the
importance of vitamin D and why you
should take it and why people are
deficient I needed to create an opposite
video on when not to take vitamin D
silly because there's always an
exception to the rule that being said I
do want to mention that vitamin D from
my viewpoint is the most important
nutrient simply because it's really hard
almost impossible to get from your diet
and people are not outside anymore
like they used to so they're not going
to get it from the Sun and the
consequences of not having enough
vitamin D for the immune system for your
bones for your joints creating a whole
back pain that being said there are
certain conditions where you'd want to
avoid taking vitamin D there's really
only one side effect from taking
excessive amounts of vitamin D and that
would be hypercalcemia okay too much
calcium in the blood
simply because vitamin D helps you
absorb calcium by 20 times in the
intestines so if you're getting too much
calcium in the blood that could be a
problem specifically for the kidney okay
kidney stones out of all of these
symptoms for hypocalcemia bone pain
excessive urination muscle weakness
right here and depression and anxiety
kidney stones would be the most serious
but since a kidney stone is really a
supersaturated calcium deposit with some
oxalates or uric acid if you were to
consume 2 to 2.5 or more liters of fluid
per day and keep your ox let's kind of
low by avoiding almonds and spinach and
have some lemon juice that would cut the
risk way way down and the second thing I
want to mention is these conditions that
I'm talking about are usually states
where you're also low in vitamin D but
sometimes you're not supposed to take
vitamin D because of this furnace right
here but some doctors will put you in
vitamin D they'll just monitor the
calcium in your blood which i think is a
smart thing for example the first
condition started
which is a condition which involves
along the skin the lymph nodes that can
involve other organs where you have this
these abnormal immune cells that are
stuck in the lungs encapsulating foreign
toxin or microbe or something but really
in only four to seven percent of the
cases they'll seat hypercalcemia not in
100 percent of the cases and actually a
very low percent of cases but it's just
something you should look at if you have
this condition and you're taking vitamin
D alright next condition is primary
hyperparathyroidism this is a situation
we have a tumor affecting the
parathyroid and that's producing a lot
of parathyroid hormone which is dumping
a lot of calcium into the body so you
can actually have this condition right
here and it could end up in the kidney
as well so you just want to be aware of
taking too much vitamin D or any vitamin
D if you have this condition all right
number three this is a rare genetic
disease which I probably shouldn't even
put on the list because it's so rare but
I wanted to just mention it familial
hypocalcemic hypercalcemia
in this condition you have hyper too
much calcium okay and so that would be
one condition we you would want to avoid
vitamin D before lithium can have an
effect of creating excessive calcium in
the blood so that is another thing on
the list okay number five diuretics
specifically hydrochlorothiazide so the
problem is as you get rid of the fluid
you can also get rid of calcium which
could end up in your kidney so if you
take more calcium it's gonna cause more
calcium to go in the blood and end up in
the kidney potentially but it's
something to know about okay number six
certain cancers will cause hypercalcemia
and number seven if you have a hyper
thyroid condition where your thyroid is
working too much that could dump a lot
of calcium into the blood as well so
realize these are the things that occur
very rarely but the most common thing is
someone has a deficiency but this is the
main problem and some of the symptoms
that could potentially happen with
this could be kidney stones bone pain
excessive urination muscle weakness and
depression alright thanks for watching
so if you want more knowledge on how to
create a healthy body subscribe now and
get daily notifications